now in the United States US senator
Bernie Sanders has dropped out of the
race to become the Democratic
presidential nominee that leaves a
former Vice President Joe Biden as the
presumptive challenger to President
Donald Trump in November sander says it
was a tough choice I know that there may
be some in our movement who disagree
with this decision who would like us to
fight on to the last ballot cast at the
Democratic convention I understand that
position but as I see the crisis
gripping the nation exacerbated by a
president unwilling or unable to provide
any kind of credible leadership and the
work that needs to be done to protect
people in this most desperate hour I
cannot in good conscience continued
about the campaign that cannot win and
which would interfere with the important
work required of all of us in this
difficult hour and that's been Isana
zealots speaker to Allen Fisher who's
been listening in he joins us from
Washington DC via Skype and Allen I
guess it doesn't come as a surprise does
it no he's really been politically dead
man walking since Super Tuesday that was
really when Bernie Sanders lost momentum
you remember the Joe Biden didn't do
well in the first three contests in the
caucuses and the primaries but then he
came back from the political dead in
South Carolina after that he immediately
got the endorsement from Budaj edge from
Klobuchar that was significant and
important for him and he did very well
on Super Tuesday it made things very
very difficult for Bernie Sanders but
when he talks about how he has moved the
political debate in the United States
there's no doubt over the last four
years he's done exactly that people are
now talking about providing some sort of
universal health care in the United
States they are talking about free State
College for people in the United States
he's taught they are talking about
income equality because of the issues
that Bernie Sanders has raised now
Bernie Sanders did not give an
endorsement to Joe Biden that's not
surprising because you don't give away
all your cards at the table he wants to
make sure that a lot of the ideas a lot
of the things that he's been talking
about
or form the platform of the Democratic
convention and also the democratic
election platform as they move in to the
presidential campaign that you remember
40 years ago that Bernie Sanders lost to
Hillary Clinton he gave his support then
but many of many of his supporters did
not want to vote for Hillary Clinton and
stayed away from the polls that led to a
lot of people pointing fingers at their
supporters saying the electrum pin I
don't think that'll happen this time
room because Bernie Sanders describes
Donald Trump as the most dangerous
president the United States has had in
its history he says that Joe Biden is a
good guy he will try and rally his
supporters to support Joe Biden come
November and for Joe Biden the way is
now open for him but he does have a
problem doesn't he in the in the sense
he doesn't have well it doesn't have the
platform of his opponent some people
would say that can be a positive and it
can be a negative he doesn't get to hold
big rallies he doesn't get free media in
important swing states but then he
doesn't stand in front of the White
House every night and do what Donald
Trump does which ends up with a great
deal of criticism on Twitter and also in
the the media comment area
Donald Trump has said that Bernie
Sanders has essentially lost the
nomination because of Democratic Party
imaginations it's what he said back four
years ago and he's appealed to Bernie
Sanders voters to come and vote for him
the difficulty that Donald Trump of
course has is that many people who had
described themselves as democratic
socialists don't automatically see
Donald Trump as a natural home and
Donald Trump is doing that for a big
reason because he hasn't been able to
grow his own base so to do that you try
and take away from someone else's base
which in this case would be Joe Biden
but certainly in all the matchups that
we see Joe Biden beats Donald Trump and
many of the key states in the election
come November but the election is in
November not know exactly all right
Allen thanks very much indeed I don't
fish either Washington DC